they give you these softball ridiculous
nonsensical things if you're a Democrat
if you're a republican they just lie
about literally everything you do and as
you guys know the main guy they're lying
about these days is the guy that they
view as the big threat and of course
that is Ron DeSantis from the free state
of Florida
we shouldn't Overlook that the anti-woke
guy Ron DeSantis his ideal is Putin's
Russia where there are no gay people
where there are no women in power where
you know they're all Christians that's
how he wants to see the world that's the
world that's why they love Putin and
they love Auto televised mental
institution of MSNBC like really think
about how insane that is no one is
coming for the gays of Florida gays are
doing quite well here because they live
in Freedom and are treated equally under
the law Ron DeSantis is not coming for
the women or the black people or any of
it but this is what they do so now I got
one more clip for you and then we're
going to get to the Community Q a so
think about it you've got sort of the if
you take Sam Harris and say he was part
of the intellectual side of the left
making at one time good Arguments for
leftism or liberalism he's he's sort of
gone off the deep end calling for
censorship of trump etc etc then you got
your Kamala harrises the type of people
that literally don't know what their
jobs are and then you've got people like
Joe Biden who literally lie about
everything and we just have the video to
prove it
[Music]